The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
Could I start first with
an announcement of a talk
this afternoon.
I know your schedules
are full, but --
the abstract for the talk I
think will go up on the top
of our web page.
It's a whole range
of other applications
that I would hope to
get to, by an expert.
Professor Rannacher,
his applications
include optimal control,
which is certainly
a big area of optimization.
Actually, MathWorks, we think
of them as doing linear algebra,
but their number one customer
is the control theory world,
and it totally connects
with everything we're doing.
He's also interested in adaptive
meshing for finite element
or other methods -- how to
refine the mesh where it pays
off in arrow problems,
all sorts of problems.
The math behind it is this
same saddle point structure,
same KK -- when he
says KKT equations,
that's our two equations.
I've been calling them,
sometimes, Kuhn-Tucker,
but after Kuhn
and Tucker, it was
noticed that a graduate
student named Karush, also a K,
had written a Masters thesis in
which these important equations
appeared.
So now, they're often
called KKT equations.
I think Rannacher will do that.
Anyway, I don't
know if you're free,
but it'll be a full talk in this
program of computational design
and optimization.
I don't know if you know
MIT's new masters degree
program in CDO.
So it's mostly engineering,
a little optimization
that's down in
Operations Research,
and a couple of guys in math.
So that's a talk
this afternoon, which
will be right on
target for this area
and bring up applications
that are highly important.
Well, so I thought
today, my job is going
to be pretty straightforward.
I want to do now the
continuous problem.
So I have functions as unknowns.
I have integrals
as inner products.
But I still have a
minimization problem.
So I have a minimization
problem and I'll call,
it's often a
potential energy, so
let me use P. Our
unknown function is u,
so that's a function u of
x; u of x, y; u of x, y, z.
And instead of inner
products we have integrals,
so there's a c of x.
This is going to be
a pure quadratic,
so it's going to lead
me to a linear equation.
In between comes
something important --
what people now call the
weak form of the equation.
So, this is would
be the simplest
example I could put forward
of the calculus of variations.
So that's what
we're talking about.
Calculus of variations.
What's the derivative
of P with respect to u?
Somehow, that's what
we have to find,
and we're going to set
it to zero to minimize.
Then why do we know
it's a minimum?
Well, that's always
the second --
the quadratic terms here
are going to be positive.
So we have a positive
definite problem.
Positive definite means
things go this way, convex,
and you locate the
bottom, the minimum
is where the derivative is zero.
But what's the derivative?
That's the question.
It's not even called
derivative in this subject,
it's called the first variation.
Instead of saying
first derivative,
I'll say first variation.
And instead of writing
dP/du, I'll write --
where can I write it?
So this is key word,
so this is going
to be the first
variation, and I'm
going to write it with a
different d, a Greek delta,
dP/du.
It's just sort of a
reminder that we're
dealing with functions
and integrals of functions
and so on.
So it's just change the
notation in the name
a little as a trigger
to the memory.
But this board
really has a lot --
not all the details
are here, of course.
This is a summary of what the
calculus of variations does.
So it takes a
minimization problem.
So I'm looking for
a function u of x.
And always since we're
in continuous problems,
we have boundary conditions.
So as always, those could be --
let me imagine that those are
the boundary conditions.
So I would call those
essential conditions.
Every function that's
allowed into the minimum
has to satisfy the
boundary condition.
So it's a minimum over all u
with the boundary conditions,
with those boundary conditions.
There are two kinds of
boundary conditions,
and maybe I'll postpone thinking
about boundary conditions
till I get the equations,
the differential
equation inside the interval.
So all these intervals
go from zero to one.
I won't put that.
We're in 1D.
So, how do you find
the function, u of x?
that stands for du/dx.
So the given data
for the problem
is some load, some
source term, f
of x, which is going to show
up on the right-hand side,
and some coefficient
c of x, which is going
to show up in the equation.
They depend on x, in general.
Many, many, many physical
problems look like this.
Sort of steady-state
problems, I would say.
I'm not talking about
Navier-Stokes fluid flow
convection, I'm talking about
static problems, first of all.
So here's the general idea of
the calculus of variations.
It's the same as the
general idea of calculus.
How do you identify a
minimum in calculus?
If the minimum is at u,
you perturb it a little,
by some delta u, that I'm going
to call v to have just one
letter instead of two here.
You say OK, if I look at that
neighboring point, u plus delta
u, my quantity is bigger.
The minimum is at u.
So we're remembering calculus --
I guess I'm saying I've written
that here.
Compare u with u plus
v, which you could
think of as u plus delta u.
It's like -- v you might think
of as a small movement away
from the best function.
In calculus it's
a small movement
away from the best point.
So let me draw the calculus.
If you think of this blackboard
as being function space instead
of just a blackboard, then I'm
doing calculus of variations.
But let me just
do calculus here.
So there's the minimum, at u.
And here is u plus v near it.
Could be on this side or
it could be on this side.
Those are both u plus
v. Well, you maybe
want me to call one
of them u minus v.
But the point is v
could have either sign.
I'm looking at minimum
sort of inside, where I can
go to the right or the left.
So what's the deal?
Well, that point is then that
at that point or at that point
or at any of these other
points, P of u plus v
is bigger then what
it is at the minimum.
That tells us that
u is the winner.
Now how do we get an
equation out of that?
Calculus comes in now.
We expand this thing -- this is
some small movement away from
u.
So we expand it, we look at
the leading term -- well,
of course, the leading
term is P of u.
Then what is the next term?
What's the first-order,
first variation
in P when I vary u to u plus v?
Well, it's the whole point
of calculus, actually.
The central point of calculus
is that this is some function
that we call P prime of u times
v, plus order of v squared.
When v is small, v
squared is very small.
So what's our equation?
Well, if this has to be
bigger than P of u --
I could just cancel P of u --
so this thing has to be bigger
equal zero now.
I've squeezed it in a corner,
but since it's calculus
we kind of remember it.
Also, it's easy to learn
calculus and forget
the main point.
So this has to be
greater equal zero.
Now this is going to
be -- if v is small,
this is going to be very
small, so it won't help.
So this thing had
better be zero, right?
That had better be zero.
Because if it isn't zero, I
could take v of the right sign
to make it positive,
and take v small, so
that this would dominate this.
Maybe I wanted to take
v of the right sign
to make that negative anyway.
I need P prime of u to be zero.
So that's what I end up with,
of course, as everybody knew.
That P prime of
u had to be zero.
So in that tiny picture,
I've remembered what we know.
Now let me come
back to what we have
to do when we have functions.
So what happened?
I compare P of u -- u is
now a function, u of x --
with P of u plus v.
So I plug in u plus v,
I compare with what
I get with only u,
and what's the difference?
I look at the difference
and the difference
will have a linear term from
u prime plus v prime squared
and then I'm going to take away
the u prime squared because I
gotta compare the two.
So what's left?
There will be a 2
u prime, v prime.
I'm maybe just being lazy here.
I'm asking you to do
it mentally and then
I'll do it a little better.
So the difference in
this comparison is a 2 u
prime v prime times
c, and the 2's cancel.
There's the difference
right there.
What's the difference
over in this term?
Well, I have that
term and then I
have the same term with u plus
v, and then when I subtract,
I just have the term with v.
So this is the dP/du that
has to be zero for every v.
Now I'm really saying
the important thing.
This weak form is
like saying this
has to be zero for every
v. Then, of course,
in this scalar case, it
was like a very small step
to decide, well, if this
is zero for every v,
then that's zero, which
is the strong form.
Are you with me?
So we have a minimum
problem, minimize P,
we have a weak form,
the first variation,
the first derivative,
the first-order term
has to be zero for every v. Then
if it's zero for every v, that
forces the derivative to be
zero and that's the strong form.
Now over here it
took more space.
But the ultimate
idea is the same.
We looked at P of
u plus v compared
with P of u, subtracted,
looked at the linear term
and there it is,
the first variation.
That has to be zero
for every v. I'll just
mentioned boundary
conditions now,
as long as we're
at this weak form.
Don't think of this weak form as
just some mathematical nonsense
to get to the
differential equation,
because the weak form is the
foundation for the finite
element method -- all
sorts of discrete methods,
discretization methods will
begin with the weak form,
the weighted integral form,
rather than the strong form.
I was just going to say a word
about boundary conditions.
What are the boundary
conditions on v?
So you could say well, v stands
for a virtual displacement.
Virtual meaning kind of
we just imagining it,
it's a displacement that we can
imagine moving by that amount,
but the whole point is the
nature fix the minimum.
What's the boundary condition?
Well, all the candidates have
to satisfy these boundary
conditions.
So I have to have u plus v
at zero also has to equal a,
and u plus v at 1
also has to equal b,
if I took these simple
boundary conditions.
So, by subtraction, I learn
the boundary conditions
on v. When I say all v, I
mean v of zero has to be what?
Zero.
And v of 1 has to be zero --
when we had those boundary
conditions.
Different problems could bring
different boundary conditions,
of course, but this is
easier than -- simplest.
So when I say all v,
I mean every function
that starts at zero
and ends at zero
is a candidate in
this weak form.
I have to get the answer
zero for all those functions.
Now somehow, I want
to get to this point,
the differential equation, and
why don't we give it the name
that everybody -- the two guys'
names, Euler-Lagrange -- well,
pretty famous names.
This is the
Euler-Lagrange equation.
So maybe before where I said
Kuhn-Tucker or something,
if I'm talking about
differential equations,
I go back to these guys.
Now, how did I get from
weak form to strong form?
That's a key.
If you see these two steps
from the minimum principle
to the weak form, that's
just, again, plug in u plus v,
subtract and take
the linear part.
Then it's true for all v's.
Now, how do I get
from here to here?
Notice that this form
is an integrated form.
This form is at every point.
So it's much stronger
and much more demanding.
You could say OK, that
gives us the equation --
that's the equation as
we usually see them.
I'll do 2D and that'll be
Laplace's equation or somebody
else's equation, but
minimal surface equation,
all sorts of equations.
Everything.
All sorts of
applications including
this afternoon's lecture.
How to get from here to here?
Well, there's one trick in
advanced calculus, actually.
The most important trick
in advanced calculus
is integration by parts.
Well, we use those words,
integration by parts,
in 1D here.
So I'll do that.
We use maybe somebody
else's name --
Green's formula or
Green's theorem,
or Green-Gauss or the
divergence theorem or whatever,
in more dimensions.
But 1D, I just
integrate by parts.
Do you remember how
integration by parts goes?
I want to get v by
itself, but I got v prime,
because when I plugged in
u plus v here, out came --
it's the derivative so
I've got a derivative.
So how do I get rid
of a derivative?
Integrate by parts.
Take the derivative off of v --
can I just do that this quick
way?
Put the derivative onto
-- I almost said onto u.
I'm doing integration by parts
and saying how important it is
but not writing out every step.
So I take the derivative off
of this and I put it onto this,
and it's gotta be -- and a minus
sign appears when I do that.
Where the heck am I gonna
put that minus sign?
Right in there.
Minus.
Then everybody knows that
there's also a boundary term,
right?
So I have to squeeze somewhere
in this boundary term.
So now that I've done
an integration by parts,
the boundary term will be
the v times the c u prime
at the ends of the interval.
I think that's right.
What we hope is
that that goes away.
Well, of course, if it
doesn't, then we have to --
that there's a good reason that
we don't want it to, but here
it's nice if it goes away.
You see that it
does, because we just
decided that the
boundary conditions on v
were zero at both ends.
So, v being zero at both
ends kills that term.
So now, do you see
what I have here?
I could write it a
little more cleanly.
The whole point is that the v --
I now have v there and I have v
there so I can
factor v out of this.
Just put it there.
That was a good move.
This minus sign
is still in here.
So I now have the integral of
some function times v is zero.
That's what I'm looking for.
The integral of some
function, some stuff, times v,
and v can be
anything -- is zero.
What happens now?
This integral has to
be zero for every v.
So if this stuff had
a little bump up,
I could take a v to
have the same bump
and the integral
wouldn't be zero.
So this stuff can't bump
up, it can't bump down,
it can't do anything.
It has to be zero and
that's the strong form.
So the strong form is with
this minus sign in there,
minus the derivative -- see,
an extra derivative came onto
the c u prime because
it came off the v,
and the f was just sitting
there in the linear,
in the no derivative.
So, do you see that pattern?
You may have seen it before,
but calculus variations
have sort of
disappeared as a subject
to teach in advanced calculus.
It used to be here in courses
that Professor Hildebrand
taught.
But actually it comes back
because we so much need
the weak form in finite
elements and other methods.
What I wrote over here is
the discrete equivalent.
I can't resist looking at the
matrix form, for two reasons.
First, it's simpler
and it copies this.
Do you see how this
is a copy of that?
That matrix form
is supposed to be
exactly analogous to
this continuous form.
Why is that?
Because u transpose f, that's
an inner product of u with f --
that's what this is.
That integral.
A*u is u prime in this analogy.
So this is u prime times c
times u prime with the 1/2,
and that, again, that transpose
is telling us inner product
integral.
So if I forget u prime and
think of it as a matrix problem,
that's my minimum
problem for matrices.
I want to find an equation
for the winning u.
In the end, this is
going to be the equation.
That's the equation
that minimizes that.
Half of 18.085 was
about this problem.
Well, I concentrated
in 18.085 on this one,
because minimum principles are
just that little bit trickier,
so that's 18.086.
And then, in between,
something people seldom
write about but, of
course, it's going to work,
is that I change u to u plus v,
I multiply it out, I subtract,
I look at the term linear
in v, and that's it.
That would be if I make
that just a minus sign
and put it all together
the way I did here,
that's the same thing.
So this is the weak form.
This is the minimum form,
this is the weak form,
and this is the strong form.
You see that weak form?
Somehow in the discrete case,
it's pretty clear that --
let's see.
I could write this as --
you see, it's u transpose,
A transpose C*A*v
equal f transpose v.
The conclusion is if
this holds for every v,
then this is the same as this.
If two things have the same
inner product with every vector
v, they're the same, and
that's the strong form.
You'd have to transpose the
whole thing, but no problem.
So now I guess I've tried to
give the main sequence of logic
in the continuous
case, and it's parallel
in the discrete case
for this example.
For this specific example
because it's the easiest.
Let me do what Euler and
Lagrange did by extending
to a larger class of examples.
So now our minimization
is still an integral --
I'll still stay in 1D, I'll
still keep these boundary
conditions, but I'm going
to allow some more general
expression here.
Instead of that pure quadratic,
this could be whatever.
Now I'm going to do
calculus of variations.
Still in 1D.
Calculus of variations,
minimize the integral
of some function of u and
u prime with the boundary
conditions, and I'll
keep those nice.
So that integral's
still 0 to 1 and I'll
keep these nice
boundary conditions just
to make my life easy.
So that will lead to v of
zero being zero, and v of 1
being zero.
What do I have to do?
Again, I have to
plug in u plus v
and compare this result with
the same thing having u plus v.
So essentially I've
got to compare F
at u plus v, u plus u prime
plus v prime with F of u and u
prime.
I have to find the leading
term in the difference.
So I'll just find
out leading term,
and then will come the integral.
But the first job is
really the leading term,
and it's calculus, of course.
Now can we do that one?
It's pure calculus.
I have a function
at two variables,
the function of u and u prime.
Actually, I did here.
I had a u prime
there and a u there.
Once I write it down you're
going to say sure, of course,
I knew that.
So I have a function
of two variables
and I'm looking for
a little change.
So a little change in the first
argument produces the dF --
the derivative of F with respect
to that first argument times
the delta u, which is
what I'm calling v.
That's the part that the
dependence on u is responsible
for.
Now there's also a
dependence on u prime.
So I have the derivative
of F with respect
to u prime times the little
movement in u prime, which
is v prime.
I can't leave it
with an equal there,
because that's only
the linearized part,
but that's all I
really care about.
This is order of v squared
and v prime squared.
Higher order, which
is not going to --
when I think of v as
small, v prime as small,
then the linear part dominates.
So can you see
what dP/du is now?
Now I've got to integrate.
I integrate this,
that very same thing.
This -- dx.
That has to be zero for all
v. You don't mind if I lazily
don't copy that into the
-- that's the weak form.
This was the minimum form,
now I've got to the weak form.
This is the first variation.
The integral of the change in F,
which has two components, when
there's a little change in u.
I should be doing an
example, but allow
me to just keep going here
until we get to the strong form.
So this is the weak
form for every v.
Let me just repeat that the
weak form is quite important
because, in the
finite element method,
we have the v's are
the test functions,
and we discretize
the v's -- you know,
we have a finite number
of test functions.
Well, I can't go entirely
-- I'll come back to finite
elements.
Let me stay with this
continuous problem, calculus
of variations problem.
v is v of x here, and it
satisfies these boundary
conditions.
That's the only requirement that
we need to think about here.
What's the strong form?
Also called the
Euler-Lagrange equation.
How do I get to
that strong form?
How did I get to it before?
I would like to get this
into something times v. Here
I've got something
times v but I've also
got something times v prime.
I wanted to get it
like up here where
it was times v. What do I do?
You know what I do.
There's only the one idea here.
Integrate by parts.
So I have the integral --
well, dF/du*v was no problem --
that had the v that I like.
But it's this other guy that
has a v prime and I want v. So,
it doesn't take
too much thinking.
Integrate by parts, take
the derivative off of v,
get a minus sign, and
put a derivative --
can I do it with a prime,
but I'll do better below --
onto this, and then
there's a boundary term,
but the boundary term goes
away because of the boundary
condition.
So now I have the v. Can
I make it on this board?
There's the dF*du multiplying
v, and then there's the minus --
this is the derivative d
by dx of dF / d u prime.
Now all that is
multiplying v and giving me
the integral of zero.
I promise to write
that bigger now.
But, again, the
central point was
to get the linear term times v.
That's always the main point.
Then what's the conclusion?
What's the
Euler-Lagrange equation?
This integral is this quantity
times v and v can be anything,
and I've got to get zero.
So, what's the equation?
That stuff in brackets is zero.
That's the
Euler-Lagrange equation.
Finally, let me just
write it down here.
Euler-Lagrange strong form.
In this general problem it would
be dF/du minus d by dx of dF /
d u prime equals zero.
Would you like me
to put on what a --
if F happened to depend
on u double prime,
it would be a plus -- this
would be what would happen --
just so you get the
pattern -- equaling zero.
So I've gone one step
further by allowing
f to depend on curvature,
and writing down
what the resulting term would be
in the Euler-Lagrange equation.
Could you figure out
why it would be that?
Where would this
thing have come from?
It would have come from --
there would have been a dF / d u
double prime times v double
prime in the weak form.
Then I would have done two
integrations by parts --
two minus signs making a plus,
two derivatives moving off of v
and onto the other thing
and it would give me that.
All times v, but now I've
got everything times v,
it's true for every v, so
the quantity has to be zero.
That's the
Euler-Lagrange equation,
strong form for 1D problem.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
You're right.
If we had this situation
then we would be up to --
this would typically be a
fourth-order equation and we
would have two boundary
conditions at each end.
Absolutely.
When I slipped in this just
to sort of show the pattern,
I didn't account for
the boundary conditions.
That would be one
level up as well.
Exactly.
And nature -- well, fortunately
we don't get many equations
of higher degree than four.
This would be like the beam
equation, the parallel to that
would be a beam
equation or a plate
equation or a shell
equation, God forbid.
In shell theory
they're incredibly
complicated because
they're on surfaces.
But the pattern is always this.
Well, and, of
course, they're also
complicated because
they're in 2D.
So maybe I should
say a little bit.
Could I maybe write -- I'm
trying to do a lot today.
Trying to do kind of
the formal stuff today.
So another step in
the formal stuff
would be to get into 2D,
which I haven't done.
What would be the
famous 2D problem that
leads to Laplace's equation?
So 2D, what would I
minimize, just to --
so P of u would be a double
integral of du/dx squared --
maybe times a c
-- du/dy squared.
I would really like 1/2 on
that just to make life good.
Then minus a double
integral of f times u.
dx*dy, to emphasize these
are double integrals.
That's a very, very
important problem.
Many people have
tried to study that.
Euler and Lagrange would
produce an equation for it.
You might say OK, solve
the equation, that
finishes the problem.
But mathematicians are always
worried, is there a solution?
Is there a minimum?
So I'm dodging the
bullet on that one.
When I say minimize
over all functions u,
I could create problems where
worse and worse and worse
functions got closer
and closer to a minimum
and there was no
limiting minimizer.
I won't do that.
This is a problem
that works fine.
What happens to it?
Well, should we try to
do the same weak form?
We'd have a dP/du, and what do
you think it would look like?
It would have the
integral, double integral.
What would it have?
It will have a c*du/dx
and there will be a dv/dx.
But then integration
by parts will
take that x derivative off of
v and onto this, with a minus.
I did it fast, did it way fast.
Then out of this thing will
come, if I look at the v term
they'll be a dv/dy and I
take that y derivative off
of that and onto this.
Oh, I can't use d anymore,
I have to use partials.
d by du of c*du/dy.
Then the f is just
sitting there.
Oh, it's all multiplied by
v. dx/dy I didn't put yet.
Equals zero for all v.
Again, this is the same thing
that we had in ordinary calculus
where it was just P prime of u,
v equals zero.
This is a level of
sophistication up.
It's producing
differential equations, not
scalar equations.
So what's the deal?
I've done the
integration by parts,
so I've got everything
multiplying a v.
So what's the strong
form of this problem?
Well, if this integral has
to be zero for every v,
then the conclusion is that this
stuff in the brackets is zero.
That's always the same.
That's the strong form.
So that's Laplace's
equation or actually
Poisson's equation because I
have a right-hand side, f of x.
Well, those are the mechanics.
Now, what else comes into
the calculus of variations?
You've seen the pattern here.
There's one important
further possibility
that we met last time,
which was constraints.
We're dealing here with
a pure minimization.
I didn't impose
any side conditions
on u except maybe the
boundary condition.
So let me give you
an example which --
I'll just close with an example
that I'm going to follow up,
and it's going to
have a constraint.
So it'll look like the
original problem, but, well,
there will be two u's.
So can I try to
get it right here?
My minimization, my unknown
will have two components, u_1
and u_2.
And it'll be in 2D actually.
What I'm going to produce here
is called the Stokes problem.
I'll study it next time, so if
I run out of time, as I probably
will, that's part of the plan.
So it's Stokes and
not Navier-Stokes.
All I want to do is to write
down a problem in which there
is a constraint.
So I write it as a minimization,
say, dv_1/ d -- oh,
probably all these
guys are in here.
dv_1/dx and dv_1/dy and
dv_2/dx and dv_2/dy --
sorry about all this stuff.
Probably an f_1*v --
oh, I've written v,
because my mind is saying
that the usual notation,
I should be writing u
because that would fit with
today's lecture.
It's a velocity and that's
why many people call it v,
and then they have to call
the perturbation some w.
f_1*u_1, f_2*u_2,
all that stuff.
No problem.
That would lead to Laplace's
equation, just the same,
Poisson's equation.
But I'm going to
add a constraint.
This [u 1, u 2] is a
velocity, despite the letter.
I want to make the
material incompressible.
I have flow here and
it's like flow of water,
probably incompressible.
So incompressible means that
dv_1/dx plus dv_2/dx is zero.
So that's a constraint.
How the heck do we deal with it?
So I could do this minimization
but with the constraint.
So all this stuff I'm
totally cool with now.
That would just be
calculus of variations,
that would get me
the dP/du, but I have
to account for the constraint.
So how do you account
for a constraint?
You build it into the problem
with a Lagrange multiplier.
So I multiply this thing by
some Lagrange multiplier,
and as I emphasized last time,
Lagrange multipliers always
turn out to mean
something physically,
and here it's the pressure.
So it's natural to call the
Lagrange multiplier p of x, y.
I build that in, so I subtract
the Lagrange multiplier
times this thing
that has to be zero.
That gets in the problem.
Now my function now depends
on u and the pressure.
I'm not going to push
this to the very limit
to find the strong form.
But the strong form is
the Stokes equations
that we'll study.
So we have a lot to
do here to make this
into practical calculations
where we can compute something.
And finite elements is
a powerful way to do it.
So we have to turn these
continuous problems
into discrete problems.
And then, later, we have to
turn this type of problem, which
will be a saddle point problem
because it's got this Lagrange
multiplier in there,
into a discrete problem.
Let me just stop by putting
the words saddle point there,
and just as in the lecture
this afternoon, saddle points
appear as soon as you have
constraints and Lagrange
multipliers.
Well, thanks for your patience.
That's a lot of material
that will quickly -- Now,
those basic steps will be
section 7.2 and will go up
on the web quickly, just as
soon as we get them revised.
And I'm writing notes
on your projects
and I hope I'll have
them ready for Friday.
I'll aim for Friday because
Monday is Patriot's Day
and you have to
run the marathon.
So I'll see you Friday.
Good.
Thanks.